known as the park witnesses include the
treasury department official in charge
of the program
and special inspector general neil
barofsky this is two and a half hours
this hearing of the subcommittee and
oversight investigations of the house
financial services committee will come
to order
our hearing this afternoon is entitled
tarp oversight
warrant repurchases and protecting
taxpayers we'll begin this hearing with
members opening statements up to 10
minutes per side then we'll hear
testimony from first witness
after that members will each have up to
five minutes to question our witnesses
i will then excuse our witness and
invite the second panel of witnesses to
give their
testimony and we'll continue with
members questions the chair advises
members that given the busy afternoon
schedule i'll be keeping everyone
including myself to five minutes
any uh unanswered question can always be
followed up in writing for the record
without objection all members opening
states statements will be made part of
the record
i now recognize myself for up to five
minutes for an opening statement
the past month or two it's been nice to
see some good news regarding the tarp
after some upbeat results from the
stress test on the largest financial
firms 10 of the largest banks holding
companies were authorized to pay back
68.2 billion dollars of tarp funds
if you include smaller banks a total of
over 70 billion dollars has been repaid
to u.s taxpayers
and this news coming after the treasury
department used more than 200 billion
dollars for more than 600 banks to
stabilize the financial sector
when congress enacted tarp last year we
authorized the treasury department to
request that firms receiving tarp funds
issue warrants
this provides an opportunity for
taxpayers to share on the upside for
their investments
these warrants give us the right to buy
shares of a company at a set price at
some point in the future
much like an employee stock option but
as you might imagine whenever the
government's the key actor in
executing these warrants unlike an
employee stock option there are a number
of other policy issues and concerns that
we have to be
deal with and have to be weighed even so
i'm firmly committed to doing all we can
to ensure taxpayers are fully repaid
on may 8 old national bank corps became
the first tarp recipient bank to repay
its tarp funding and repurchase their
warrants held by treasury
the bank paid 1.2 million dollars to buy
back these warrants but what concerned
me was a professor from the university
of
louisiana and lafayette professor linus
wilson
analyzed his transaction very closely he
determined that the warrants were worth
at a minimum 1.5 million dollars in as
much as 6.9 million dollars
so at the low end treasurer was off by
300 000
and in the worst case treasury missed a
return of an additional five point four
million dollars
five million dollars might not sound
like a lot of money when we're talking
about billions of trillions of dollars
in financial rescue aid
but if you consider the 600 other banks
that will eventually need to repurchase
their warrants this money quickly adds
up to a big potential return for u.s
taxpayers
i wrote a letter to secretary geithner
on june 2nd urging him in knowing
certain terms that he act to protect the
taxpayers investments in these
firms by max maximizing returns on these
warrants
i carbon copied sig tarp cop and gao and
two weeks later received a joint letter
from special inspector
general barosky and professor warren
expressing their commitment to
transparency
they noted a coordinated effort between
cop and sigtar to review
quote whether those warrant repurchasing
procedures provide fair value to
american taxpayers end quote
early this month i was glad to see cop
issue a report entirely focused on tarp
repayments including the repurchase of
stock warrants
similar to the analysis done by
professor professor line as cop
found in the first 11 banks that
repurchased their warrants treasury was
receiving only 66 percent of what they
could have received for taxpayers
cop notes that these small banks
represent only a fraction of one percent
of all warrants issued
but if this trend continues taxpayers
could miss out on an additional 2.7
billion dollars worth of returns on
their investment
but on the same day the cop report was
released we received some good news when
wall street journal reported that jp
morgan chase
had decided to pursue repurchasing its
warrants through a public option
they were frustrated with the treasury
department for demanding too high a
price for their warrants
i'm very glad the treasury department's
holding a tough line especially against
the largest of the tarp recipients
and today goldman sachs announced
they'll pay 1.1 billion dollars to
redeem their warrants
representing a return of 23 percent for
u.s taxpayers
that sounds pretty good but it is enough
i'll keep pushing to make sure every
single tarp dollar that helps stabilize
our financial sector is fully repaid
so that our children and grandchildren
are not left with a tab i look forward
to hearing from our witnesses today
especially the new tarp administrator
and assistant secretary for financial
stability mr herb allison
he has one of the toughest jobs in the
country and look forward to treasury's
viewpoint
on how they weigh these difficult
decisions to stabilize the financial
sector
while protecting taxpayers and the
strong oversight congress put in place
when we
created tarp continues to publish what
amounts to thousands of pages of
oversight reports
all free and available online examining
every angle and aspect of tarp
just this week sigtart published their
third quarterly report
i look forward to hearing mr borofsky
professor warren and mr mccool's
testimony today
i now recognize for five minutes the
ranking member of the subcommittee my
colleague and friend
from illinois ranking member judy baker
thank you mr chairman for holding this
hearing today
the hearing which which is intended to
focus on a specific
aspect of the tarp program warrant
repurchases and protecting taxpayers
it is in the taxpayers best interest
that as soon as possible the federal
government
gets out of the trillion dollar bailout
business and out of the practice of
owning and running private businesses
this is something the administration
also supports how soon can we withdraw
taxpayer money and end the practice of
taxpayers propping up industries
treasury the fed and the fdic must
communicate to the markets
and taxpayers the exit strategy and the
timeline for it
we need to put an end to the federal
government picking winners and losers in
the marketplace which has facilitated
unfair competition competitive
advantages for some businesses and
completely abandoned others
it's also in the taxpayers interest that
treasury secured the best possible
return on its investment
i think we'll hear some criticism from
some of our witnesses today that
treasury
is shorting taxpayers on the investment
from what i understand this may or may
not be true
the accusation may be more for headlines
than than true
and is based on differences of opinion
as to what is the best
modeling method methodology to value
warrants
whatever the case taxpayers must be
insured
assured that treasury is using the best
means to recapture taxpayers money
and i hope that mr allison will provide
us with those
assurance today and i agree with many of
our witnesses today that taxpayers
deserve transparency
with regard to warrants and with regard
to what tarp recipients are doing with
taxpayer money
at the same time i want assurances from
today's witnesses
that as they work to improve tarp
transparency and while tarp is still
active they will not jeopardize treasury
and taxpayers
negotiating position to secure the best
return on their investment
it is also vital that we prevent any
individual
federal entity or business involved in
tarp from making a profit based on
insider information especially when it
is at the expense of the
taxpayer that's unacceptable and i want
to know what is being done to prevent
this
finally i'm disappointed with
legislation that would siphon off tarp
returns
when we still don't have a guarantee
that tarp will ultimately
ultimately produce a return or loss for
taxpayer
at a time of record deficits and
unemployment reaching 10 percent
nationwide any profit on this tremendous
risk should first and foremost go
towards paying down the deficit with
that i would like to uh yield
the balance of my time to the ranking
member of the financial services
committee
uh mr bacchus thank you and
thank you mr moore for convening today's
important subcommittee hearing
on the oversight of the tarp program and
i also like to recognize ranking member
biggert's
fine service she's been
particularly i think helpful on the
issues involving the
sec and the cftc
i thank you last fall
congress required recipients of
assistance under the capital purchase
program to issue warrants to the
treasury
i have a particular interest in this
program because i first proposed it
or something like it on september the
18th
uh and felt like uh by setting
uh you know a dividend or at least a
repayment at a certain percent
i felt like we would be best assured of
receiving a fair return
as opposed to a more
fluid definition
for instance when you buy toxic assets
and i said that in the
very first meeting with secretary polson
and
chairman bernanke you know what do we
price these at if you price them
too low it doesn't help the banks with
their capital
if you price it if you pay too much for
them it's a bad deal for the taxpayers
so
i've always thought that this was our
best
opportunity of safeguarding the
taxpayers and yet coming to the aid of
the banks and i think
time has shown that to be correct
and i chairman frank and i and others
worked on a bipartisan way on this along
with
representative roy blunt
and this was done so that the american
taxpayer would have the opportunity to
benefit
the warrants particularly from any
upside as these companies returned to
financial health
and although we we were hoping that was
the case now
some of them have had a spectacular
return
and you saw today with goldman sachs
paying back the money
there was a 23 annualized return
now that's going to be unusual i think
but it certainly was
good news for the taxpayers however many
questions do remain about
how to properly value these warrants to
ensure that
taxpayers receive a proper return on
their investment
and i know miss warren
or professor warren or dr warren
you had proposed that they be placed on
the open market for sale
to the highest bidder and certainly that
that is a
uh you know one option that you
you know has some appeal uh particularly
if
if the treasury and the uh the party
cannot come to some agreement i think
that's probably
the only valid option and normally i'd
be favor of letting the market decide
asset values in all cases
and i do think that the oversight
panel's formula for setting the auction
price
could result in the holding the
government having to hold the warrants
for a
extended period of time and then you
have to you have the risk of
another economic downturn so you're if
you knew
that the economy was going to continue
to recover
uh or the company's prospects i'd say
yes but you know you look at the
commercial mortgage
market and others and you're it's really
again you're
it's a somewhat speculation and
i've advocated trying to particularly if
the treasury sets a price
and it's accepted let the taxpayers get
their money back
we'll go ahead and get that money back
in the treasury where it can
be used to pay down the deficit
in the july report on additional views
my colleague mr hensling
explained that the valuation of the
warrants is a highly complex
analysis and a one-size-fits-all
approach may not yield the best results
for
the american taxpayer you know i i agree
that that's
that's true while the july report
seems to paint a picture that some money
may be left on the table
if it's if its valuation formula is not
used
i believe that a far better result for
the american taxpayers i said is
is to go ahead and as soon as possible
get the federal government out of the
business of holding
stocks and warrants of the financial
institutions
and treasuries indicated that's also
their policy so
to get this the government's investment
uh
back as soon as possible uh let me
conclude by saying mr chairman
uh as institutions begin to pay back
their tarp assistance and really capital
purchase
program monies we need to end
bailouts return the money to the
taxpayers not recycle the funds
back into more bailouts and part of that
will be regulatory reform
to ensure that we don't have any more
bailouts
and i think protection of consumers is a
part of that
uh and although my approach differs from
chairman
frank i believe that that we what we
ought to be doing is saying to the
regulatory agencies which have the skill
and the means and the resources to
enforce consumer protection that we give
them the charge
to do it and tell us how they're going
to do it
and if if over the period of six months
to a year we see that's not working
then we could address it in a more more
novel way
but let's be clear about another fact
although the capital purchase program
may earn a profit
the tarp program overall will not
so for that reason i believe that all
these dividend pay
payments ought to be given back to the
treasury as soon as possible
mr chairman thank you for your
indulgence of my opening statement
and thank you thank you as well mr
chairman i now recognize mr klein for
two minutes
thank you mr chairman uh for holding
this important hearing and
this is one of those hearings we should
have a lot more press coverage and a lot
more attention to the fact that we're
having a pleasant discussion about uh
the tarp
and the scenario where not only are
large banks that
were probably put in a more solid
position
after what happened in september but
their
the consideration now is not only paying
back the initial capital
but what's going to happen with the
bonus that's the warrants and for those
people who aren't familiar with warrants
that's obviously that upside
that we've been talking about all along
so there's a very positive
discussion going on here today and i'm
glad that members of both sides of the
al can can recognize that that doesn't
mean that things are
good for everyone but this is a little
bit of silver lining
to the fact that the taxpayers of the
united states who put all this money on
the table are going to get not only the
money paid back
but we'll share on the upside now that
being said i want to
in my opinion and i appreciate the
witnesses today and had a chance to meet
with
many of you and talk to you about some
of the specifics and thank you for your
service
it's very important part of the
oversight here is making sure that the
taxpayers received the maximum
return for the risk that they took not
everybody wanted to go along with this
but we
did what we had to do and those people
who
said we didn't need to do this um it's a
matter of history to judge but at the
at the present time we want to wish all
of our businesses and banks the united
states success
we want them to succeed we want them to
lend more and a strong message i'd like
to deliver to the banks
that our top recipients is start lending
start moving along here i mean we have a
liquidity issue
in the united states that still is out
there and whether or not you're paying
back the money
or the warrants are going to be
exchanged in some form or fashion
we need you to be a part of our recovery
that being said the fairness part of
this is making sure we get the maximum
bang for the buck and whether it's on an
auction
or whether there's a wait or not a void
again i'll leave that to some of the
professionals who can help us realize
that we get the maximum
bit of value back from the banks that
end up taking this money some of them
are now recording historic profits uh
which again we wish them all well
uh we want that success to filter out to
others as well
but we want to make sure that the
taxpayers in this country
who literally went on the line to make
sure the recovery was
going to begin and it seems to be
beginning now
that we can put some of this money back
in the till and
those banks that may need some
additional help and other others around
the united states may get that help
but other than that we get the maximum
dollars back thank you mr chairman
thank you mr klein the chair now
recognizes ms mary joe kilroy for two
minutes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
conducting this hearing
although i was not part of the 110th
congress
and voted no on the house plan to
release more money from the trouble
asset relief program
i understand that the american taxpayers
took on some risk
when we worked to bail out the banks
many of whom made decisions that have
hurt ohio's families
and hurt ohio's economy in fact the hurt
our country's economy
now as main street still awaits the
economic recovery
and the jobs that it deserves some banks
are back to making record profits again
after receiving our help and i think
that it's appropriate that the american
public receives a return on the
investment that they made
with the tarp money i find it
unacceptable that the downturn hurt
main street hardest yet the recovery
seems to be
benefiting corporate america first
this issue the repayment of the
taxpayers
and the upside of warrants is one
situation where the taxpayers
deserve to reap the full benefits in an
open and transparent
process according to the reports that we
have received from dr warren from mr
borowski
the banks and treasury are negotiating
the repayment of this
debt the purchase and sale of these
warrants
behind closed doors instead of allowing
the transfer and the trading
to happen on the open market and allow
the market to set the price
we do not know if the current process is
producing the benefits we are owed
however dr warren has found that we are
getting about 66 cents on the dollar for
our investment
and that the total shortfall to our
constituents could be as much as 2.7
billion dollars
a market-based approach would remove the
secrecy and special interests
and maximize the return on taxpayers
investment
that is why i introduced with six of my
colleagues what we call the profit act
this logical and common sense bill would
maximize profits for our taxpayers
and ensure transparency by requiring an
open process
eliminating the loophole that allows
banks to negotiate behind closed doors
with treasury
the public auction would be such a
transparent open market
and i think that one of our witnesses
assistant secretary allison
stated earlier this year
in his testimony that in relation to
toxic
assets on bank balance sheets quote we
have our theories but in the last
analysis
that's why you have financial markets
you have to have liquid interchanges
and then the truths will come out as to
what assets are
actually worth quote
i look forward to today's testimony and
i suggest to the panel and to my
colleagues that
now is the time to act to close this
loophole
according to the congressional oversight
panel which dr warren heads
less than one percent of the warrants
those stock options for the american
people
have been sold this is the time to push
treasury to open the process with
transparency
and to make sure americans get the deal
that they deserve
thank you i yield back thank you miss
kilroy for your statement
and it's now my pleasure to introduce
our first witness mr herbert m allison
jr the newly confirmed assistant
secretary for financial stability at the
u.s department of the treasury
as assistant secretary for financial
stability mr allison is responsible for
developing and coordinating treasury's
policies on legislative and regulatory
issues affecting financial stability
including administering tarp
mr allison most recently served as
president and ceo of fannie mae as well
as the chairman president and ceo of
tiaa-cref he has held senior positions
at merrill lynch time warner in the new
york stock exchange
mr allison also spent four years as an
offering officer in the united states
navy including a year in vietnam
without objection your written statement
will be made part of the record mr
allison
mr secretary assistant secretary you're
recognized for five minutes to provide a
brief summary of your statement
uh chairman moore and ranking member
biggert and members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to discuss
treasury's efforts to stabilize and
repair
the nation's financial system in
response to the major crisis in our
nation's financial system and housing
markets
congress passed emergency economic
stabilization act or esa
last october establishing the troubled
assets relief
program or tarp and giving treasury the
necessary tools and flexibility
to stabilize the financial system and
restore the flow of credit to consumers
and business
our mandate in esa is twofold to
stabilize the financial system
while protecting the taxpayers today i
want to update you on our progress
in just 10 months treasury has invested
more than 200 billion dollars
in 657 financial institutions
of all sizes in 48 states including over
300 small and community banks
through the capital purchase program we
reopened
the capital purchase program recently
for small and community banks
recognizing the critical role these
banks play in our communities
we provided support to three
systemically significant institutions
we launched an unprecedented housing
program to help millions of homeowners
we assisted with restructuring of both
general motors and chrysler through the
bankruptcy process
and as a result both companies are
better able to compete today
we help to restart the securitization
markets a key source of credit
to consumers and businesses
we launched the public and private
investment program to help remove legacy
assets from the balance sheets of
financial institutions so they can
redeploy their capital
to support lending and we issued
regulations guiding executive
compensation at all firms receiving tarp
funds
we have allocated about 643 billion
dollars to our esa programs
we've actually invested 362.6 billion of
that amount to date
we've also received over 70 billion
dollars in
cpp payments from 34 institutions
and 6 billion in dividend repayments
from participants in all the tarp
programs
and finally we're beginning to receive
proceeds from the sale of warrants
through the ccp
and as was noted today we received 1.1
billion dollars from goldman sachs
representing a return of 23.15 percent
on the taxpayers money as you can see
treasury has accomplished a great deal
all about building a new office of
financial stability
however we have much more to do as
described later in my testimony
i would like to briefly discuss
treasury's process for selling the
warrants it has received through the cpp
i've attached our policy statement and
our frequently asked questions on this
subject with my testimony
for the record treasury has communicated
its consistent and clear process for
valuing warrants
in a manner that protects taxpayers we
apply the same process consistently
for all banks large and small
treasury is committed to getting fair
value for the taxpayers for these
warrants
and we've made that process public on
our website
when a publicly traded institution
repays treasury's investment under the
cpp
it has the contractual right to
repurchase its warrants at fair market
value
through an independent valuation process
directly from treasury
one source of complexity in valuing
warrants
is that the warrants do not trade on any
market
so they don't have observable market
prices
models by themselves cannot give us
reliable estimates of the realizable
price
in the marketplace so we're using a
comprehensive approach to estimating
these values
which involves a variety of inputs
including a set of well-known financial
models
in developing our valuation and
repurchase process
we counsel with numerous experts market
makers and industry participants
treasury also consults with third-party
market participants as to what they'd be
willing to pay for the warrants
and we obtain full independent
valuations from outside
investment managers treasury decided to
sell the warrants within several months
after they're eligible for sale
rather than hold them for a substantial
period
our guiding principle is the president's
belief that the extraordinary government
interventions necessitated
by the crisis should be unwound as
quickly as is consistent with treasury's
mandate under isa
to restore liquidity and stability to
the financial system
while protecting the interests of
taxpayers as with all
aspects of our financial stability
programs treasury welcomes the
recommendations and comments of others
as we continually strive for improvement
transparency
and accountability in all of our
programs
earlier this month treasury announced
its selection of nine asset managers for
the legacy securities public-private
investment program also known as p-pip
to remove legacy assets from the balance
sheets of financial institutions
the p-pip is a critical element of
treasury's financial stability plan and
is designed to support market
functioning
and facilitate price discovery in the
important asset-backed securities
markets
allowing banks and other financial
institutions to redeploy capital
and extend new credit to households and
businesses
treasury took a number of comprehensive
measures to enhance the potential of
this program
and to protect the taxpayer we consulted
closely with the sig tarp
as we developed a robust framework for
compliance governance and controlling
conflicts of interest
treasury also ensured that the p-pip
includes a spectrum
of minority women and veteran-owned
businesses that represent our
communities
the tarp has been key to stabilizing the
financial system
and preventing greater deterioration in
the availability of credit to households
businesses
and communities amid signs of recovery
in the financial markets in the first
half
we've seen improvement in spreads
that is the measure of the risk in the
financial system
we've also seen that issuance of
corporate debt has increased sharply
there are also some signs that the
economy is beginning to mend
consumer confidence has increased
significantly housing starts have moved
higher
house purchases have begun to pick up in
some parts of the economy
nevertheless our financial system and
our economy remain vulnerable
even with the modest improvement in
conditions unemployment
and the level of home foreclosures
remains high
strains in the commercial real estate
market continue to build
this is why treasury must remain
vigilant and press ahead with our
financial stabilization efforts
upon taking office president obama
committed to increase
transparency accountability and
oversight in our government's approach
to stabilizing the financial system
secretary geithner further underscored
treasury's commitment to transparency in
all our programs
one of secretary geithner and my
priorities is to ensure that we enhance
and provide transparency
as our activities evolve i will
regularly
update congress on our progress we have
productive working relationships with
our four oversight bodies
the special inspector general of the
tarp sig tarp
the government accountability office gao
the congressional oversight panel the
cop
and the financial stability oversight
board or fincob
treasury has accepted a great majority
of the recommendations
of those bodies where we conclude that a
recommendation is impractical
we find other means to achieve the same
goal
treasury shares the concerns of congress
and our oversight bodies that we see an
increase in lending by banks
and we've required banks receiving a
treasury investment
to report their lending activities
regularly
in january treasury launched an
important initiative to help the public
easily assess the lending activities of
banks participating in the cpp
starting with the top 21 banks since
they account for over 50 percent of
lending in our communities
then in march we expanded the survey to
include all banks in the cpp
and have now published three lending
reports with data from over 500 banks
because we believe these reports are
critical to helping the public
understand the lending environment
during this crisis
we have asked 10 large banks that have
repaid treasury's cpp investment
to continue participating in the survey
through the end of this year
and they have agreed and we appreciate
their voluntary cooperation
treasury is working urgently to maximize
the impact of our programs on financial
stability
but we must allow some time for these
programs to have their full effect
we recognize that we have much work
ahead
to restore the flow of credit to
consumers and businesses
and alleviate the real hardships that
americans face
every day as my colleagues and i work on
this
important financial stability effort we
will strive to be prudent investors
on behalf of the american people and to
protect the taxpayers who have entrusted
us
with so much of their money here are the
top priorities of the office of
financial stability
first we will carefully review the
controls over taxpayers money
giving special attention to compliance
with laws and directives governing risks
and internal audits in this regard we
will work closely
with congress and the oversight bodies
second
we will strive to maximize the
effectiveness of financial stability
programs
restoring soundness to financial
institutions and liquidity to our
markets
and finally we will emphasize
transparency and interaction with
congress
so that the american people will know
what we're doing with their money
why we are doing it and how it's helping
the financial system the economy
and their lives thank you very much and
i look forward to answering your
questions
thank you for your testimony mr allison
i now recognize myself for five
minutes for questions mr allison as you
know goldman sachs announced they're
buying back their warrants for 1.1
billion dollars directly from the
treasury
yet jpmorgan chase is going to a public
auction because according to news
reports
there's a feeling you are driving too
hard a bargain which i'm frankly glad to
hear
is 1.1 billion enough for goldman's
warrants
would taxpayers have received more if
they went to a public auction
uh thank you chairman moore for your
question it's a question that we ask
ourselves all the time
we have even though we're contractually
obligated
to go through this process of
independent valuation with a bank if it
chooses to do so
if the bank decides it would rather
auction the warrants
we are willing to go that route uh we
have
modeled both approaches of course as i
mentioned in my earlier
testimony a month or so ago
we can't tell for sure how the market
will end up valuing warrants
we try our best if the process is going
to be the
independent valuation approach mandated
by contracts
to get market-based information
nonetheless and so that's why we go out
and we ask market participants to give
us quotes
on these warrants we are satisfied based
on those quotes
based on analysis by independent asset
managers and based upon our own
use of valuation models similar to that
used by the cop
that this is a very fair price for
taxpayers we're comfortable with that
and although i still can't tell you that
we would do better or worse
out of the open market nonetheless based
on a system we use for every bank and
have since the beginning
we are very pleased with this outcome
thank you
mr allison what's your response to the
paper from professor linus on old
national as well as cops reports saying
the treasury could miss out on a
potential 2.7 billion dollars worth of
returns for taxpayers
what policy issues does treasury
consider when reviewing these warrant
repurchases
and also i've heard some say auctions
should be held shortly after earnings
season
say early august providing transparency
to all potential buyers
when will treasury hold these auctions
in response to our view of the process
of the cop
first of all we use a similar model to
the cop
we respect their approach we've had
discussions with the cop about ours and
about theirs
there are as the cop report pointed out
small differences in the assumptions
that go into a model
especially when you're valuing warrants
as long as 10 years can have a major
impact on the result of the valuation
and in in this case
one of the assumptions has to do with
whether
there should be a discount to the price
baked into the model
because small banks have much smaller
warrant positions
that we hold and when they're sold
there's likely to be less demand
less liquidity in the market and
therefore a lower price
we factor in for small banks a discount
for the the lack of liquidity of those
warrants
so that's one reason why there could be
a difference between
the model outcome of the cop and ours
uh i would also uh ask that you look at
the comments of various cop members
addended to the to the cop report where
they point out
some of these issues i think we have to
be
while we're all trying to do our best to
value these warrants
we all have to respect the uncertainty
of a model and that's why we use
alternative approaches such as going
into the market and asking real market
participants
what they think the warrants are worth
and my
final question mr allison i know you've
only been on the job for a month but
have you given any thought to a tarp
exit strategy do you have any sense of
how long we should expect tarp to be up
and running
the law creating tarp requires after
five years the president must submit a
legislative proposal to congress of how
the financial services industry will pay
for any remaining outstanding losses on
the program
since we're nearing the one-year
anniversary of the law do you expect
that we will have losses on the program
in four years do you have any
yes sir uh the uh the east of
legislation provides that
at the end of the year we might end
making investments in companies however
the secretary of the treasury
can make a determination uh as to
whether the program should be extended
that is for making investments until
october of next year
the secretary will be deliberating that
matter in the fall
and will reach a decision
i should point out that the
features of these investments either
contain expiry dates for our investments
or
increasing costs to the uh to the
to the bank in which we're investing so
there are incentives built into the
program
for banks to repay treasury uh as
rapidly as their financial condition
allows
thank you sir my time is up and this
time i recognize uh
miss bigert for any questions she may
have for you sir
uh thank you mr chairman um uh
this is sort of um similar but mr
allison
you know the treasury is being
criticized for not securing the best
possible
uh return on its investment in fact i
think
in the congressional oversight panels uh
the cop
recent report they accused the
treasury of uh reselling the the
warrants back to the banks that
two-thirds of their actual value
is uh and is this true
uh thank you for your question uh
congresswoman vigor this is a question
many people are asking as a result of
that report
um we have as i said uh taken various
approaches to valuing these warrants
the exact same approaches that we took
in valuing goldman sachs's warrants
and we determined based on this approach
that we were receiving a very fair value
from those smaller banks
and that's why we accepted those bids
and uh
we will eventually be disclosing more
information
that lay behind those bids
and our decision and we look forward to
making that
information available down the road is
there a difference because
the small banks have probably less
liquidity
than the larger banks yes that is true
in fact we did as i mentioned apply a
liquidity discount in the model
that was also by the way reflected in
the market indications that we received
we did not apply a liquidity discount in
the case of goldman sachs
and we would not in the case of other
larger banks because
given the value of those warrants
they're more likely to enjoy a liquid
market
if they were auctioned okay can you give
the
the taxpayer the american taxpayers
assurances that treasury is doing
is using the very best means to re
recapture the taxpayers money i can
assure you they were making every effort
and this is our obligation to the
american public to receive
the inappropriate and ample return
for the taxpayer we know they're the
ones who put their money at risk and we
feel every great obligation as
responsible stewards of their money
well you received a fair value but was
it
is there a difference or the best value
we believe that this
that in each of these cases these were
ample values and we've applied the same
standards to all
so we examine each method
and the results that it produces and
then we determine
what is an appropriate price that we
should demand
from each bank and we stick to that
price
as i uh i mentioned in my opening
statement it's vital that we put
you know prevent any individual or
fiduciary
entity or business involved in tarp from
making a profit based on
insider information especially when it's
at the
expense of the of the taxpayer what's
the treasury doing
to prevent and track this
we've had many close consultations with
the sig tarp
we have also invited the sig tarps
staff to meet with us and the uh
and the candidates to be asset managers
on the p-pip program for example
uh i think we've had a robust dialogue
with inspector general barofsky and his
team about this
we are charged with promoting financial
stability
while protecting the taxpayers our
mandate and the reason for the law
is to build and implement programs that
are going to eventually help
the american public and the financial
system
and so with that in mind uh we have
decided
on an approach where we and the sig tar
will have the access to trading data
across each of the fund managers
that we're hiring daily so we and the
sig tarp can check
trading in the various funds of each of
these fund managers
to see whether in fact there are any
questionable trades that might cause us
to wonder
whether we're getting full value for the
taxpayers money whether
a manager is trying to take advantage of
our
investments at the benefit of one of
their other investments so we have
almost real-time ability to intervene
we're also getting
uh certifications from the managements
of these funds
we are prohibiting fund complexes from
having one fund
trade with our fund as another control
so we have we think very robust controls
to protect the taxpayer in uh in mr
borowski's
quarterly report which was released
yesterday he highlights the fact that
treasury has declined to institute
barriers to prevent the conflicts of
interest with the management of the
ppi program maybe this was
before you've worked something out with
him but
but thinks that this could have serious
consequences related to money laundering
or could you
or could lead to increases in
government's exposure
to losses um with no corresponding
increase in potential uh profits
is this accurate well we carefully uh
considered sig tarp's recommendation we
welcome sig tarp's ideas i may say that
uh the sig tarp has suggested dozens of
ideas to us
and we look back and we we've accepted
or
in in a way very similar uh accepted
the sig tarps recommendations about
three-fourths of the time there are some
cases where we have determined
that in the interest of uh financial
stability
and because we can find other ways of
protecting the taxpayer
that we uh we declined to implement
and one of these cases has been the
creation of a wall now in many cases
and here i draw upon 35 years experience
in the financial services industry in
many cases
it makes great sense to have a wall to
separate asset managers in one area
from asset managers in another in the
case
of the asset managers we're hiring on
behalf of the taxpayer
we want to have their best talents
working for the american taxpayer
in the p-pip fund and but these managers
in these fund complexes are already
committed to
other funds that they manage the the
fund cannot take them away from those in
order to focus on ours
conversely if we allowed the best
managers to stay with the other funds
we'd have to have them hire other
managers without the track records that
are the reason why we hired those fund
complexes
so we've we have instead of having a
wall
we provide transparency the ultimate
test
and i've worked with walls a wall
can be defeated by people determined
to collude they can leave the workplace
they can go out in the street and talk
to each other they can use cell phones
to talk to each other
even if you have a wall you have to make
sure the wall is working
that's why we're insisting on managing
on these managers making available their
trades across the whole fund complex
every day
so we have the ability to get total
transparency in what they're doing
pin them down right then and there if we
see suspicious trading activity
in order to protect the taxpayer thank
you thank you and
with all respect i'm going to have to
advise the members and the witnesses
that we have
we've just been advised that we have
votes being called the next 15 to 30
minutes
there are six votes which i anticipate
will take about an hour
so i'd like to move along here and i
would advise members and the
witness too that they'll have an
opportunity to submit additional
information
for the record written responses if they
would please thank you ms gilroy you're
recognized for five minutes thank you mr
chairman
mr allison thank you for being here this
afternoon
it's my understanding um
that the tarp statutes initially
permitted treasury
to convert a warrant to cash or to
exercise it
when treasury decided that doing so
would allow the public
reasonable gain and that the market was
optimal for such assets and that the
goal of that was to maximize
the value for taxpayers is that correct
is that your understanding
yes yes congresswoman in fact
the the law has changed several times
since the esa law was
enacted and recently
we've been given the ability again the
flexibility
to sell the warrants at a time of our
choosing when we think it's in the best
interest of the taxpayers
and do you believe that is still this
despite the changes in the law the goal
to maximize return for the taxpayer we
we believe that
selling the warrants relatively soon
after we are repaid
by the bank for its preferred stock
investment
that it is appropriate for us to sell
the warrants
in a way that will benefit the taxpayers
and the reason
for this one of the reasons is that a
warrant
value is based on a stock value that
incorporates the markets
expectations regarding the future
performance of the stock
so even if we sell the warrants over the
near term we're not forfeiting the
upside potential
of of the warrant we also find
if we hold the warrant for a longer
period of time and here it gets a little
bit technical
the option value of that warrant
declines we also
would engage in market timing if we hold
the warrant for a long period of time
and we are not in the business of being
long-term investors
conducting market timing trying to find
the right time to sell a stock and
frankly there never will be
any agreement on what is the right time
to sell separate apart from the timing
issue
is there an issue in terms of protecting
the taxpayer and protecting taxpayer
confidence in the process
of the methodology by which the warrants
are
sold or converted to cash well
we uh uh again where we
are going to be disposing of the
warrants we first have to follow a
contractual process
where the bank that issued the warrants
has the ability to bid
to buy back its warrants we don't have
to accept their bid
in fact in most cases we have not
we we will let them rebid
if they wish if they decide
to no longer bid then we have the
ability to go out
and auction those warrants in the open
market
the contractual process
would would you agree gives is more
one-sided and gives the banks more
authority in setting
uh the methodology for the sale and
of the warrants actually congressman
i think that puts the treasury in a very
good position to represent the taxpayers
we do not communicate what to us
is the price that we require in order to
sell in that process
the bank has to bid we will not accept
until there's a bid that reaches our
considered
price and at that point if they reach
that price and some don't
we will sell and we think at that point
we are capturing
ample value for the taxpayer
let me also add that i know there's
concern and you voiced it
about whether we're doing this in a
closed room
we are going to be disclosing uh
information about the methodology
and the actual calculations that we used
in arriving
at the appropriate warrant price i
mentioned at the appropriate time
right now we're engaged in discussions
with a number of large banks
we think it's in the taxpayers interest
that we defer that disclosure
until a later date you do understand
would it be your understanding that the
treasury would have
no authority to enter into contracts
with the banks regarding the tarp money
other than that flowed from the statute
that set up that
program in the first place i'm aware
that
all of our actions on behalf of
financial stability in the office of
financial stability
are carrying out the law of the esa law
and that would include the obligation to
protect the taxpayers interest first
and to to use the phrase from the
from issa to maximize the return for the
taxpayer
absolutely thank you
yield back the ranking members
recognized
thank you mr chairman i just have
unanimous consent to allow
two members of the general financial
services committee but not of the
subcommittee to participate today that's
mr brad sherman of california
and mr kenny martin of texas without
objection so ordered
mr bacchus congressman baucus excuse me
you're recognized next
been called a lot worse than that
mr allison the act we passed back on
october 1st the eesa that includes the
tarp and the capital
of purchase plan
it states explicitly that
proceeds from the sale of troubled
assets
and revenues from dividends and the
surrender of warrants
shall be paid into the general fund of
the treasury for reduction of the public
debt
and of course that was part of the
bargain
in passing that act yes sir
the treasury has interpreted that and
this is
according to mr um bravsky's
most recent report you interpret that
the maximum amount of funding is 299
billion so as long as
you don't you don't have that much
funding out
that you can replenish the fund as
opposed to returning it
to the general fund is that
correct the limit that was set
on the amount of investments outstanding
at any one time
is 700 billion dollars yeah okay as i
mentioned
currently that number is a little over
360 billion dollars
we have uh budgeted
to spend about 643 billion dollars to
date
however we have also received repayments
as you know of over 70 billion dollars
so far
and that together creates headroom uh
under the
700 billion outstanding in one time of
about 128 billion dollars to date
so what you've interpreted that is
this when you get these dividend
payments that you don't have to they
don't have to be returned to the general
fund
all the monies that we receive are
returned to the general fund and then
under the esa law
didn't he draw back out as well under
the issa law we may make uh
additional investments so long as we do
not exceed
700 billion dollars outstanding at any
one time so it it just deposited in the
fund and then exposed
it and then there is a new decision and
a new allocation
okay all right um
i'm sure you're aware chairman frank has
introduced tarp for main street yes sir
which is legislation to use the dividend
payments and i guess the warrant
payments too i'm not sure about that to
fund
several public housing initiatives
instead of the money being returned to
the treasury
was this type of use of tarp in your
opinion ever envisioned by the treasury
department
uh let me first say that the treasury is
carefully looking
at chairman frank's proposals
and we
also however believe that it's important
to maintain the headroom
that we have today uh keeping in mind
that while conditions have improved a
great deal
there are still strains in the financial
system banks are still facing pressures
uh but let me go back and say that we
are carefully analyzing
chairman frank's proposals and we will
be
coming back to chairman frank with our
thoughts
you have any initial concerns with you
know legislation that draws out of that
fund
for purposes other than what was
authorized in the e
uh i think we need to have more
conversations about
exactly what form that would take before
i could draw a conclusion
yeah it really sounds to me like y'all
have not
taken any hard approach that you're not
going to reach into that fund for
all sorts of new ideas i i would
not presume at this point to speak
on whether we might or might not uh
be funding some of those initiatives out
of the target
funds and but we are considering it very
carefully
sure would you have conversations with
the
minority as you move forward to
let me say uh congressman that
uh i look forward to meeting with
each member of the committee and i'd be
glad to discuss and respond to any
questions or suggestions that you may
have for us
well let me have one last quick question
that
rahm emanuel has said that the obama
administration has rescued the economy
do you agree with that assessment
i would say that the uh that the esa law
has played a very important role in
improving the
financial markets and the soundness of
the financial industry in the united
states
which has already had measurable
benefits for the american public
sure and i i do agree that the act that
was passed last september has had
benefits i associate myself
i'm not sure that we can pronounce
victory
a former president did that in a you
know foreign policy matter and it came
back to biting
as this president has said uh we it's
going to take time
to heal this economy and to heal the
financial system right
thank you thank you mr spear you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
allison for joining us this afternoon i
have been listening to the discussion
um although i haven't been present in
the room but i do have a couple of
questions for you
the the inspector general for sig tarp
was before another committee yesterday
and he was very clear
that no one in treasury has come over
to review the surveys that he has
received from every one of the banks in
terms of how they are using tarp money
i find that absolutely in
unbelievable and irresponsible that
one agency of government has been able
to access information has the
information
and nobody from treasury has
looked at it no one from your shop has
looked at it and i want to know
why not well thank you for your question
congresswoman um first let me
compliment the inspector general
barofsky
for his initiative i look forward to
seeing the information
as do my colleagues and we'll be happy
to meet with him about this
so you're committing to this committee
now that you are going to
meet with the inspector general and
review the material that he has
developed in the survey of 360 banks
i'll be very pleased to meet with him
great
in his report that he issued yesterday
he said although treasury has taken some
steps towards improving transparent
transparency and tarp programs it has
repeatedly failed to adopt
recommendations that
sigtart believes are essential to
providing basic transparency and fulfill
treasury's stated commitment to
implement tarp
with the highest degree of
accountability and transparency possible
now one of their recommendations is that
a treasury should require all tarp
recipients to report
on the actual use of tarp funds
treasury has declined saying that
reporting would be
meaningless and i got to tell you that
my
constituents probably don't think it's
meaningless to know precisely where
their taxpayer dollars
are going so my question to you is will
you actually adopt
that particular recommendation well
first of all
um we welcome the recommendations of the
sig tarp and the other oversight bodies
as i mentioned earlier in my testimony
we have
adopted or very come very close with a
few minor details to adopting
about three-fourths of the
recommendations that we have received
well there's only five there's only four
recommendations here and he says you
haven't adopted any of them i just want
to get a clear answer will you
or will you not make public
how the money that's been received by
these banks
in tarp have been spent
let me uh first of all point out that
every month we provide
comprehensive information on our website
financialstability.gov
about the actual lending activities of
all the banks
in which we have invested mr allison
with all due respect i'm asking a very
simple question and i just want a simple
answer
either you're willing to do it or you're
not willing to do it
well we think that the most important
information for the either yes or no
will you do it we are we have looked at
that
possibility our concern which we have
mentioned
is that if we let me give you some
examples
this is a capital purchase program its
intent is to provide capital
to banks we disclose
all those activities every capital
transaction whether we invest or whether
we receive monies back
is posted on our website within 48 hours
there is voluminous information about
that once the
money has been invested on a daily basis
the banks may be
shifting the use of the funds their
dynamic institutions
if they report one day the money has
been used for this
another day it can be changing
furthermore because the money is all
placed
in a cash account as it's received and
money is fundable
it while the bank may say that they have
let's say put 50 million dollars mr
allison
i i hate to interrupt you but my time is
very limited and you've just used up
another two minutes
um this is my request to you
mr boroski believes that you can put
this
on a public place for public uh
distribution i'm asking you to work with
him
and find a way by which the taxpayers of
this country are going to be able to
access this information
and know how the banks are spending
their money i want to know and i
i'm really getting tired of many
of the people in the administration and
frankly some of my colleagues
in congress protecting the banks we
should be protecting
the taxpayers and the taxpayers have
every right to know
how their tarp money is being spent the
gentlelady's time is up and uh the next
person we recognize is congressman
mchenry for five minutes
uh thank you mr chairman and uh thank
you for your testimony mr allison
um i think to my colleagues point here
um you know money is obviously fungible
right so it would be very difficult for
you to say
that it's the 100 billion dollars or
one billion dollars that this
institution got that they lent here
the whole deal that's fair to say that's
right
okay now
the point that i think many of us have
is we're concerned about what's
happening on main street you know
how that money is actually being lent so
to get more precisely at my colleague's
question
are you able to track track lending
standards
for these various institutions
while we post the actual information on
lending by all those banks
which we think is very important for the
public to know
we are not the regulator for those banks
we don't oversee the bank's lending
standards
our role has been under the esa law to
provide capital
to promote the stability of those banks
not to manage the banks
and not to regulate the banks the
regulation is
used by other regulatory agents
obviously but in terms of disclosure
and tracking those lending standards are
you doing that
we are not tracking the individual
lending standards
of each bank okay uh i i assume that the
regulators are very much involved in
monitoring the lending standards
yes but we have you before the the the
congress about
tarp funds and tarp funds which are then
being lent out or not being went out
and the sig tarp report says that
obviously this can be done to track
lending standards and so we'll get to
that in the next panel with that i'd
like to yield the balance of my time to
my colleague from new york mr lee
it's very kind of you sir thank you
thanks just a a
quick question it it and it gets back to
and i got to tell you
that the taxpayers in my district are
very frustrated with the
what we are doing in washington and the
concern over the the debt that we have
in this country
now at the end of this year the
projections are being close to two
trillion dollars
and understandably i think it is very
positive news in the fact that we have
i believe you mentioned somewhere in the
neighborhood of 70 billion dollars being
paid back
but overwhelmingly i hear from my
constituents at the need that we need to
start paying down this
this debt rather than it sounds like
what i heard from you today is that
we just plan on keeping this program
going on in perpetuity or at least over
the next five years so
dollars come back are being potentially
re-injected into the market and
potentially going to places outside what
their
original purposes were stated or the
potential to do so
is that a fair statement let me make
clear congressman and thank you for that
it gives me an opportunity to clarify
that that concern
under the esa law the treasury
would no longer make investments
in uh institutions after the end of this
year
unless the treasury secretary makes the
determination that
it is in the interests of the economy
and of the nation to extend this program
until october of 2010.
that's what the law this is not an
open-ended unending
investment program and in the
investments themselves
there are built-in incentives to pay
back the money the cost of the funds
in many of these programs rises over
time
in some the program itself expires over
a period of time
so we are very mindful of the need to
protect the taxpayers interest to get
the highest possible return we can to be
careful stewards of the money and we
also understand that this program
in terms of making investments will
terminate at some point
in the not too distant future
nonetheless
the government may still hold
investments
for a longer period of time and we are
preparing
for that eventuality to make sure we
continue
to have the procedures the policies and
the personnel
to be responsibly overseeing those
investments
thank you thank you yield back my
thank you and the chair now recognizes
mr grayson for five minutes
thank you and i will remind everybody in
the room that votes are about to be
called so we'll probably go another five
to seven minutes after votes are called
and then
recess the hearing and come back after
votes are concluded
you recognize sir thank you
on page three of your statement mr
allison you say we have provided capital
to 657 institutions across 48 states
including over 300 small and community
banks enabling
banks to absorb losses from bad assets
while continuing to lend to cus
consumers and businesses
we continue to invest in banks every
week
in terms of that statement mr allison i
think of this myself as
a distinction between good banks and bad
banks
good banks are banks that have been
profitable have remained profitable
through
uh the economic disaster that we've
experienced the past year and a half
are well managed can assess risk
properly and they're fundamentally
different from the bad banks
the bad banks have basically taken bets
often with taxpayer provided money
government provided money they made bad
decisions
and unfortunately for all of us many of
the people at those banks are still in
charge of those banks making more bad
decisions every day
now it seems to me that if you provide a
dollar worth of capital to a good bank
that bank might be able to make ten
dollars with the loans that's the
fractional reserve system that we live
under
if you provide a dollars worth of
capital to a bad bank
that bank certainly is not going to be
able to do any more than provide ten
dollars with the loans
it also will try to cover its losses
maybe pay out more money to its bad
management maybe pay out money to its
shareholders
and not do what we're trying to do
through this program so
why is it that we do something like
enable
banks to absorb losses from bad assets
in this program
why don't we invest in the good banks
not the bad banks congressman thank you
for the question
we are investing in banks that are
deemed to be viable
by their regulators and banks
voluntarily come to us but they must be
deemed to be viable banks
now some viable banks have bad assets
but those viable banks are still very
important to their communities
and so as part of the financial
stability effort
we're helping banks to
recover stabilize so that they can
continue lending in their communities to
businesses large and small and to
individuals to keep the economy going
well following this line of questions
wouldn't we be better off if we gave the
same amount of money to good banks banks
that were functioning well so that they
could expand their operations and make
more loans rather than propping up bad
banks
that have made mistakes that have cost
all of us congressman these are viewed
as
good banks with some bad assets
and uh as banks that can be viable and
ongoing and continue to serve their
communities
how do we get to a point where a good
bank has a bad asset i mean seriously
doesn't that reflect some really bad
choices on the part of the management of
that bank whenever they have a bad asset
well i think that virtually every bank
has some bad loans on his books
and what we've seen is because of
prices of real estate have declined so
much commercial as well as residential
a number of companies have had to go out
of business because of declining
economic activity
loans that seem to be quite good when
they were granted
turn out to be not so good in an extreme
environment like today
and yet we have had banks that make the
right decision are you familiar with the
concept of moral hazard
yes sir aren't we inviting serious moral
hazard
by continuing in this way to prop up bad
banks rather than helping good banks
expand their operations
and letting capitalism work well sir we
have to keep in mind that uh these banks
have to pay us back
and we've been well paid back just today
by one of them
and uh we're working uh making every
effort to make sure that the taxpayers
who made these investments
uh uh obtain an appropriate return
that's our responsibility to work on
their behalf
at the same time these funds are going
to
help stabilize not just the banking
system but the economy which benefits
all americans and we have seen that the
banking
condition has improved we've seen that
home sales are starting to stabilize in
many parts of the country
the risk of the financial system has
declined which is good for everybody
and we're hopeful that by continuing to
provide the support as the banks need it
that we're going to have a strong
underpinning to begin this recovery that
we're also anxious to see
but resources are always limited even
for the federal government
wouldn't we be able to accomplish all of
that and more if we directed our support
to good banks rather than to propping up
bad banks
well again i i believe that many of
these
uh were good banks that
uh were uh active in lending in their
communities
and we're now seeing a financial
situation that this country hasn't
experienced since at least the 1930s
this has been an
extremely serious decline
in asset values that's affected every
american
we have to keep the economy going the
whole purpose of this program as enacted
by congress
last year was to inject capital into the
banking system
so it could not only survive but
stabilize as soon as possible
i see my time is up but i would urge you
mr allison to give some thought to the
subject
if you are continuing to invest in banks
every week give some thought to
investing in the good banks not the bad
ones
thank you for your advice i appreciate
it thank you mr paulson you're
recognized sir
i'm for uh for five minutes thank you mr
chairman mr allison you mentioned in
your testimony
um that you could not comment on some of
the existing negotiations and
discussions you're having with some of
the banks given that they're trying to
buy back some of the warrants that they
have that are outstanding and
yes sir i've had some questions come
back from some of these folks that i've
interacted with about other different
set of rules etc that apply them but
you also mentioned your testimony that
if treasury and these firms or these
banks cannot agree
on a fair market value for these
warrants that the warrants would be sold
then by treasury on a public auction
correct
yes sir is there a timeline on that
public auction
of when that would be is there a time
frame that would be put in place when
the auction would actually take place
are there guidelines are there
stipulations that you can share a little
bit more about yes sir
uh thank you for the question we're
actually working hard on those
guidelines now
they're not yet completed at when they
are
we will provide more information we want
this to be as transparent a process
as possible but we've had to give very
careful thought since this amendment to
the act
was put into place on how we might best
do this in a way that protects the
interests of uh
taxpayers okay and just knowing that
it's in the interest of protecting
taxpayers as you said and repaying and
kind of re
unwinding all this that has taken place
right
you don't foresee this is going to be
like another year or no sir okay that's
just kind of curious on that i also want
to mention to um you know is
from your estimation all the work you've
done in this issue do you think that the
tarp funds
have been equitably reaching the smaller
financial institutions
well most of the institutions that have
received tarp funds are small
and we have uh at least 300
quite small and community banks and
other small institutions who've received
these funds nonetheless we are concerned
about uh making sure that
small banks which are so vital to their
local communities and account for an
outsized portion of small business
lending
are able to continue lendings that's why
we reopened
the cpp program in may i think it was to
make it possible for these banks to if
they needed
tap into the cpp facility and we've had
a number we have a number every week
who are coming to us for uh for that
funding
and giving us their preferred stock
we're also looking at other ways
of assisting small business and we may
have some announcements to make about
that before long
and this was a question i was going to
ask also for the next panel but it seems
at least i'm hearing differently
uh from some of the smaller financial
institutions about their inaccessibility
of some of the opportunities for these
funds and
i'm just curious if you might have a
perspective on why i might be hearing
that perspective well uh first of all
i'd like to know the names of those
banks congressman if you can provide
them to us we'll get in touch with those
banks as soon as possible
they also should be talking with their
regulator we
we make investments on the
recommendation of the bank's regulator
so the first stop should be the
regulator and
then we will consider the investment
thank you thank you
mr margin texas you recognize for five
minutes sir
thank you sir could you do
just to real quickly discuss the concept
of the head room that you were talking
about earlier
uh you've got a 700 million dollar
basically cap on the amount of money
that you can put out at any given time
yes sir so now that we're
pretty far into this program you also
have an inflow of money
yes sir so you have kind of a revolving
fund
so if you uh is it public how much
the goldman sachs transaction was worth
today
let me uh make clear that um uh when
money is repaid to us
it's put in the general account of the
us treasury
okay and uh so the headroom
is the difference between the amount
that we have budgeted
and uh and the amount
that uh of of the total uh limit which
is 700 billion dollars
plus the amount that's been repaid so we
have budgeted totally about 643 billion
but we've also repaid money
and when you add the repayments to the
difference between the 643
and the 700 billion you end up with
about 128 billion dollars of what we
call headroom which we think is
important to have at this point
in this economic crisis in case
banks find that they need additional
funding in order to
maintain their activities and preserve
their financial strength but
when you define budget you mean that
those are funds that you've already
committed that have not been these are
firms
that we have have uh uh
allocated uh and we may use
for certain purposes let me point out
that at that uh
at this moment uh we have uh invested
about 360 billion dollars
okay but and so the difference between
the 360 and the
643 i believe it is what we
we have more or less earmarked for
additional usage so when you say
allocated
it may be a an asset type allocation but
not a specific obligation to fund
a bank uh as far as the cpp program goes
that is correct yes sir so if the
if congress reauthorizes the extension
to october 2010 is that correct
well it would be the treasury secretary
who has the authority to extend the
program
until october 2000 so if the treasury
secretary
authorizes the extension to 2010 yes sir
then this this whole dynamic process
of of headroom and inflow
and outflow remains the same
i mean you've got that you've got that
pretty well fixed in
in the way you're going to do that yes
sir then
2010 is there a possibility to extend
beyond that
on the part of the secretary or is that
would that be a congressional act
i believe that the the treasury's
authority
uh the treasury secretary of the
treasury's authority extends through
2010 to extend that and then and that's
to disperse
and then the repayment follows that
payments could continue for some time
and then but then there's no there's no
longer any outflow it
is all in flow that that's my
understanding of how it works yes sir
and as far as
what if you ended up with a situation
where you had
in excess of the 700 because of the
repayment of the tarp
and the sale of the warrants and the
redemption of the preferred and the
interest paid
do you mean we would not be above 700
billion we'd be well below it
you you've already forecasted that you
there there's a limit
on the amount we can have outstanding at
any one time invested
on behalf of the public that's 700
billion dollars so the money basis we
may not exceed that number so it goes
into the treasure
treasury in the in the in the in in the
general fund yes sir
but we've already raised the debt
ceiling
to include that out that that
appropriation correct
sir you're getting beyond my expertise
well i mean is there an
issue is there a snapback provision in
in the bill that says as the money comes
back into the treasury
then the money is paid paid down on the
debt
or do we not already have
through the rate by raising the
the budget isn't the money really
captured in the
in the federal government golfers i will
get back to you on that but it's my
understanding that as the money comes in
that reduces the national debt as it
comes in
okay but let me let me give you a more
definitive answer on that as soon as
possible okay thank you
thank you i thank the gentleman and i
would
at this time thank you mr allison for
your testimony you are excused i invite
the second panel to sit down we have
just a very few minutes i think before
votes are called we'll go as long as we
can all right look we'll go five or
seven minutes
yes sir i'd just like to introduce into
the record the
special inspector general's report
on the bank's use of money
which does show that 83 percent of them
told the sig that they were had used it
for lending
even the four percent that said they did
it or had not used it
they had or had not used it had so i
mean it does
i think indicate at least some evidence
of that
the u.s banks are using the tarp funds
to increase lending
some of them did it to maintain their
capital levels and
stay in business to keep the doors open
so without objection will be received
into the record
thank you and uh thank you mr allison at
this time
thank you i invite the second panel to
be seated i'm pleased to introduce our
second panel of witnesses for this
afternoon's hearing
for this panel we'll start with and
welcome back mr neil borowski the
special inspector general the troubled
asset relief program better known as sig
tarp
next we're glad to have with us again
professor elizabeth warren
chair of the congressional oversight
panel and finally we'll hear testimony
from
mr tom mccool director of the center for
economics at the
at the government accountability office
thank you all for being here and without
objection your written statements will
be made a part of the record
you'll each be recognized and i think
votes are just now being called i think
we can again take the first witness
you'll be
recognized for a five-minute statement
summarizing your written testimony
inspector general borowski recognized
for five minutes sir
thank you mr chairman it is uh it's an
honor to be back before this committee
thank you it's also an honor to be
sitting next to uh
two of our most important oversight
partners of course professor warren from
the congressional oversight panel
and mr mccool from from gao um
this week we we've introduced and
presented our
our most recent quarterly report and the
oversight that we've been conducting
over the past
quarter and so much of that oversight is
a result of the coordination that we've
had
with our oversight partners and one of
the things we strive for
for of course is to coordinate the
oversight the tarp has gone
from a uh a 700 billion dollar program
which is large enough in its own right
so now being expanded with with activity
with the federal reserve and the fdic
into a
almost three trillion dollar program and
this is more than any
any one of the three of us and our
organizations could ever cover alone
and we've strived to coordinate that
oversight working with gao
our important audit partner trying to
cover as much of this terrain as
possible
and we recently are putting forward a
joint audit project our our first
on corporate governance utilizing the
the experience and activity of both of
our agencies
and we've recently uh this month did a
coordinated project with uh
professor warren and the congressional
oversight panel uh the first part was
was there
i thought their excellent valuation
report in their july report and the
conclusions there
we're going to be using that as context
for an audit that we've launched into
the warrant repurchase process
basically in our report that we've that
we've just
delivered this week i'll just very
briefly describe
what's contained in there in section two
of the report we do a brief overview
of what's happened in the last three
months in the tarp and there's been a
lot of activity
from the bankruptcy of the auto
companies
from repurchase of more than 70 billion
dollars of capital per in the capital
purchase program
from the selection of the nine asset
managers and the commitment of
approximately thirty billion dollars of
taxpayer money in the public private
investment program
in section three of our report we
attempt to put that in context
by giving detail surrounding
approximately 50 other
programs you know so often a particular
tarp recipient
not only accesses the tarp but will
access other parts of the financial
bailout from the government
whether it's a loan guarantee from the
fdic or
borrowing money from the federal reserve
and what we've attempted to do in our
report is bring transparency to that
by setting out approximately 50 of the
program's most significant programs
that have been implemented or discussed
and described since the onset of this
crisis
in section 5 of our report we give our
recommendations
we go over our past recommendations and
have issued several new recommendations
one of them which was discussed with mr
allison was
the our continued recommendation that
treasury require
tarp recipients to to provide
information on their use of funds as was
also discussed we recently
finished our audit which was completed
and made public this monday
and we've demonstrated that
notwithstanding the inherent fungibility
of money
banks can and should be required to
report on the use of funds
contrary to mr allison's suggestions
we've demonstrated
that this is a meaningful task when we
asked the banks
what they did with the money they were
able to tell us and they were able to
tell some of the things
that uh ranking membrane that you you
described
just moments ago that that they were
able to explain how they were able to
increase lending
or at least stop the hemorrhaging avoid
further reduction of lending
banks told us that they would have come
to a standstill if not for these funds
but they were also able to explain other
uses of funds how they invested in money
how they were able to maintain capital
cushions
so they withstand future losses this is
vitally important data from our
perspective and vitally important
transparency
i understand the orthodoxy and the i the
concept of capital accounts
and i understand that perhaps that is
why treasury initially
was so reluctant to adopt our
recommendation but now that we have the
proof now that banks when asked the
banks themselves has said
we can report on how we're using the
funds we believe that these excuses
and explanations for lack of
transparency should no longer be
countenanced and we believe that
treasury
should and and in order to meet its
promised goals of bringing transparency
to this program
must adopt this recommendation we also
make other recommendations in the report
relating to other aspects of
transparency including the public
private investment program
as well as some other transparency
recommendations that have been kicking
around for some months
including the basic one that treasury
report to the american people
what the value is of their investment
treasury receives monthly
reports from its asset managers with
estimates of what the value of the tarp
portfolio is
and we believe basic transparency would
require a treasury
to make that information public
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
wrofsky and uh we votes have been called
there's
ten minutes left for votes we can hear
one more witness and professor warren
will ask you
to do a five minute presentation or less
so we can get over and vote
and then we will reconvene and have hear
from mr mccool and then have questions
of the witnesses afterwards thank you
actually mr chairman we probably got
if she takes even six minutes i think
we're in good shape
very good i think you know how fast i
talk
you very much uh thank you chairman
moore uh thank you ranking member uh it
is an honor to be here
uh again today in front of this uh
committee i appreciate your inviting us
i i want to say as i always do unlike
the gentleman to my left and right
i am part of the panel and so when i'm
here i'm not scripted
which means i speak for myself i will do
my best to represent my panel but i
represent
only my views when i open my mouth our
job
is to review the current state of
financial markets in the financial
regulatory system and to report to
congress
every 30 days so far we have delivered
to you eight oversight reports
and two special reports on regulatory
reform and
on farm credit both of which were also
required by law
we have also had nine hearings we've
been out in the field
on your behalf we will have our 10th
hearing
next monday in detroit our contribution
again our statutory mandate
is a fact-based analysis designed to
raise issues about the operation and
direction of
tarp and about the broader effort to
restore stability to the economic system
we call that asking whether or not tarp
uh is operating to benefit the american
family
and the american economy we hit three
repeating
themes and that is the need for
transparency
the need for accountability and the need
for clearly articulated programs by
treasury we coordinate closely with the
gao
and special inspector general mr
barofsky just identified our coordinated
effort
which we're very pleased to participate
in and that is a
an important part of the report we just
issued on warrant valuation
remember bacchus uh identified the key
to what the warrants are about
we understood what the risks were when
congress allocated the potential 700
billion dollars to tarp
this is the american taxpayers one
opportunity to participate in the upside
our statutory mandate is to look at the
choices treasury's making
and that really involves not just our
july report but also our june report
our general report was on uh stress
tests
the question about repayment in the
first instance
and whether the stress tests were
stressful enough
we then move to our july report once the
decision is made
to take money back from these financial
institutions what should be the pricing
on the warrants in order to do the
warrant valuation
we thought it would be helpful in terms
of oversight
to do an independent valuation uh
to ask how it is that others might value
this our own
expertise within the panel but also we
were aided by
uh nobel laureate robert merton
professor daniel bergstresser and
professor victoria evacina
all are from the harvard business school
all
advised us independently without
consulting with each other
and they helped us review our model they
helped us review our inputs
ultimately we did all of the
calculations internally to the panel
and that's how we came up with the
numbers we came up with
now our finding was that the price paid
in the first warrants that were sold
or about 66 percent of what our
valuation would show
was the current market value uh if
treasury got only 66 of current
valuation
uh as it went forward that would be a
loss to the american taxpayer about 2.7
billion dollars
now we're very careful in this report to
point out
some key features the first is only a
tiny proportion
of these warrants have been sold and
they are in very small banks and the
first sales
we acknowledge there may be differences
about what are the appropriate liquidity
discounts
to put into the valuation we also
acknowledge
that there may be considerations other
than maximizing the return to the
taxpayer
for example trying to get out of this
business of holding warrants as quickly
as possible
and those could affect the valuation i
will say however
that since we issued our report 12 days
ago
chase has decided it wants to go to
auction goldman sachs
has just struck a deal today which
adjusted for the rise in the value of
their stock prices over the last 12 days
is almost precisely at our estimated
valuation
and i heard treasury announce in this
hearing that they will be revealing more
information
about their negotiations over stock
price warrants
i think that means oversight works so
i am pleased to be here today to
give you our report to answer your
questions in
any way that we can and to talk about
alternative
approaches to valuing these warrants i
again
appreciate the invitation to be here and
i'm glad to take your questions
and thank you for your testimony
professor warren we are going to stand
in recess until
after votes and i would ask members to
come back immediately after vote so we
can reconvene this hearing and we'll
finish up
with the testimony mr mccool and have
questions by the members
thank you and i apologize for this uh
interruption of our
hearing but we do have to vote thank you
very much we'll see a little bit
that was neat
thank you very much
i thank you for the witnesses for
staying around and
for the hearing and we got back here
just as quickly as we could
mr mccool you're recognized sir for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman uh chairman moore
ranking member brigade
and members of the subcommittee i'm
pleased to be here today to discuss our
work
on the troubled asset relief program the
economic
i'm sorry the emergency economic
stabilization act that authorized tarp
requires jail to report at least every
60 days
on findings resulting from our oversight
the status of actions taken under the
program
my statement today is based on our fifth
mandated report issued on june 17th
which follows up on our previous
recommendations and covers the actions
taken as part of tarp
through june 12 2009 our oversight work
under the act is ongoing and our next
report will be issued
in the next few days and will focus on
tarps loan modification program
specifically this my statement today
focuses on the nature and purposes of
activities that have been initiated
under tarp
including repurchases of preferred
shares and warrants and treasury's
efforts to establish a management
structure
for tarp as of july 10 2009 treasury had
dispersed about
361 billion of the roughly 700 billion
in tarp funds
most of the funds 204 billion went to
purchase preferred shares
and subordinated ventures from overs of
over 650 financial institutions under
the capital purchase program
this program continues to be office of
financial stability's primary vehicle
for stabilizing financial markets
at the same time the treasury continues
to purchase preferred preferred shares
in institutions other institutions have
paid over 70 billion
to repurchase shares as of july 10th
12 of the 33 financial institutions that
repurchased their preferred shares from
treasury had also repurchased their
warrants
and three others had repurchased their
warrant preferred stock from treasury
at an aggregate uh return of about 80
million dollars although the office of
financial
stability and its regulators have
established criteria for accepting and
approving cpp applications
the regulator's criteria for determining
when institutions can repurchase
preferred stock
from treasury lack adequate transparency
this is an area in which we made a
recommendation
in our report for the treasury in
coordination with the primary regulators
to ensure consistent criteria in the
consideration of repurchases
while treasury has provided some limited
information about the warrant valuation
process
it has yet to provide a level of
transparency at the transaction level
that would address questions about
whether the department is getting the
best
price for taxpayers this is another area
in which we recommend
that treasury provide such transparency
in the process
by publicly disclosing more detailed
information about warrant prices i was
pleased to hear mr allison suggest
earlier that
treasury seems to be moving forward
within that effort
although it is unclear whether any
institutions will choose to participate
in the capital assistance plan
the federal reserve did conduct stress
tests of the largest 19 bank holding
companies
to see how well they would withstand a
more arduous than expected economic
conditions
while the federal reserve disclosed the
stress test results
it had no plans to disclose information
about the institutions going forward
what information if any is disclosed
would be left to the discretion of the
affected institutions
raising a number of concerns including
that the institutions could disclose
inconsistent
or only selected information over the
federal reserve
had not developed a mechanism to share
information with the office of financial
stability about the ongoing condition of
the bank holding companies that continue
to participate in tarp programs
for this reason we made a recommendation
to the federal reserve to disclose to
the public information on the companies
against the more advan sorry adverse
scenario on a going forward basis
while the office of financial stability
has made progress in establishing its
management infrastructure continued
attention to hiring remains important
especially within the uh office of the
chief risk
compliance officer and the homeownership
uh group those are areas where
their their hiring has not been up to
their to what they themselves say are
their
requirements they still have a number of
vacancies and they need to fill them as
rapidly as they can
treasury has also continued to build the
network of contractors and financial
agents to support tarp administration
and operations
that have been key to ofs's efforts to
develop and administer the tarp programs
treasury has provided information to the
public on procurement contracts and
financial agency agreements
but has not included a breakdown of cost
data by each entity as a result treasury
has missed an opportunity
to provide additional transparency to
its tarp operations
that's another area in which we made a
recommendation to treasury to improve
transparency
mr chairman uh this ranking member
bigger that concludes my statement i'm
happy to answer any questions
thank you mr mccool at this time i'll
recognize myself for five minutes of
questions
professor warren once people have had a
chance to analyze the transaction
do you have any sense that 1.1 billion
dollars paid by goldman sachs will be
enough for taxpayers do you think we
could have received more if goldman
went through a public auction are there
other policy issues that should be
considered
i think that thank you chairman i think
it's a good question
uh using the valuation
metrics that we laid out in our report
the goldman price comes in
almost precisely at what we had
recommended
i believe the goldman price is 1.1
billion and using
our valuation uh it would have been 1.08
billion so we're we're within rounding
error on that
and that certainly increases our
confidence
that treasury is using a
a strong valuation approach here
i i do want to say though that there are
these other issues
that that lurk in the
in the sales process and it's hard to
find a substitute
for the benefit of a public sale a
public sale reassures everyone that this
is the market price um
but i i certainly understand congressman
baucus's point there are
there are times when we decide that we
don't want to delay that we want to be
able to move faster
these are costs and benefits and
ultimately policy choices
not just for treasury but for congress
to weigh in on we think as your
oversight panel the best we can do
is outline it we can give you this
independent valuation as we've done
and put the factors in front of you
which we've tried to do thank you mr
borowski do you have any different
thoughts about that or do you agree with
what
professor warren said i definitely defer
to professor warren uh
her report and her study i think was was
comprehensive i thought it was very
instructive
uh we haven't done a similar effort
where
we we do have an ongoing audit that will
address different issues
but i i would certainly defer to
professor warren in the panel on this
okay mr borowski another question i
noticed that in addition to your
quarterly reports you issued this week
you
also concluded the use of funds quote
use of funds audit that you conducted
what did you learn from that audit and
what steps should treasury take to
increase accountability in the tarp
program
and want to ask you that sir i think the
most important thing we learned is i
think we've definitively proved
that despite the inherent fungibility of
money
banks can when asked report on how
they're using their funds
and that they can provide a great degree
of transparency
and answer that question we saw that
banks did although treasury as mr
allison noticed
noted does provide lending snapshots of
each month
that's not the only thing that banks do
with their tarp funds
according to the banks themselves they
use it to maintain capital cushions
uh insurance for a rainy day for future
losses
they use it to acquire other financial
institutions
they use it to invest in securities you
know all sorts of different things that
that our survey helped provide a
necessary level of transparency but it's
only part
of you know our survey was a snapshot as
a february
we don't have the resources to do this
on a regular basis and our survey was
voluntary
so my recommendation is that treasury
finally adopt our recommendation
require financial institutions who are
receiving tarp funds to repeal
report on a periodic basis on how
they're using the money
thank you and professor warren did you
find any connections or parallels with
the sig tarp's use of funds audit and
what's the
cop learned when reviewing the lending
practices and how it affects
american families and small businesses
yes mr chairman we did in our field
hearings and our earlier reports
we have documented the constriction in
small business lending
and the inadequacy of the tools that
have been used thus far by treasury
to try to stimulate small business
lending
we think this is entirely consistent
what we have found and reported on
with what it is that mr barofsky has
found and reported on
through a different mechanism
my time is up and at this time i'll
yield to
questions from mrs bigger please the
ranking chair
thank you mr thank you mr chairman um mr
barofsky in in talking about the
the the audit of the of the warrant and
evaluation in sales when can we expect
to see this audit
you know we're basically evaluating the
timing when we first launched the audit
it was it was unclear when sort of the
the larger institutions were going to be
either repurchasing or going through the
auction process
now that we're seeing some of these
repurchases i think we want to take a
look and see what the
the auction process for to be the most
useful audit
i think we'd like to see that process be
used before we
we project a an end date okay and
can you ensure that the the audit will
not compromise
uh the treasury's department to uh
negotiate
uh the best possible price for taxpayers
do you think there's any
uh chance of that happening if if the
audit is out and they're negotiating
with everything that we do including
this and any of our audits and really
with our recommendations uh it's
inherent upon us i think it's very
important for us
to take into consideration the the point
that you just raised
we would never uh make a disclosure
midway through a negotiation anything
that could possibly
uh impact in a negative way on on the
taxpayers return
our job is to protect the taxpayers
interest and we're very very sensitive
to these types of issues and
and protecting confidential information
uh to the extent it may impact or
be a detriment to the taxpayer thank you
then uh professor warren the july uh
report issued by
uh cops states that the best manner to
sell these warrants is on the open
market however
and as my colleague mr hensarling stated
in his additional views to that report
choosing a one-size-fits-all method does
not seem to be
the most appropriate method to value
these warrants
given that each repurchase negotiation
will have different circumstances
don't we need flexibility in the process
to help determine the best value while
getting the taxpayers
out of the business of owning bank
stocks or warrants
congresswoman i actually think the
report says
exactly that that there should be
flexibility we talk about the advantages
uh to an open market process but we
acknowledge that there are circumstances
that may differ
and um uh i assume that is part of the
reason that congressman hensarling voted
for that report
we we had a 5-0 vote on the valuation
but the additional there's always
additional views
i think he cited the report extensively
right do you um
in in determining like fair market value
do you use uh
you know financial models or is it just
the one a one-size-fits-all i mean like
black shoals or
is that you take that into consideration
of course uh
actually our our financial models are
laid out in in many many pages
in our report and as i said in my
testimony
they were independently reviewed uh the
models
were independently reviewed by uh
three highly renowned specialists in
modeling
all from the harvard business school
okay uh and three members of the panel
uh representative hensarling and i think
senator sununu
and uh richard niemann voiced
their support for the administration's
and treasury stated objective to
to exit warrant holdings as soon as as
practical after banks repay the
preferred stock
it didn't seem like this point was a
stress at all in the july report
well i i think that it's it's like so
many things it depends on the cost
um there are there is always a judgment
to be made
and exiting in the fastest possible way
in return for getting the lowest cost
for the taxpayer
may not be uh ultimately beneficial
on the other hand i certainly understand
the point about not hanging on to the
warrants for 10 years
and the political as well as economic
implications of that
so i think the the main point in the
report
was that there are advantages and
disadvantages uh
to speed uh and to going to the market
in order to try to sell these warrants
ultimately though
uh we did emphasize the point that
when there is a market-based auction no
taxpayer
needs to wonder what happened behind
closed doors or whether they apply
is that it it seemed like that was the
majority and and it wasn't really
stressed in the in the report what they
said
and and next the panel's press release
for the july report contained
the headline so far treasury has sold
warrants back at 66 percent of panel's
best
estimate of fair market value and i
think that the headline
kind of uh seemed misleading since the
the banks have all redeemed their
warrants
banks that have redeemed their warrants
represent less than one percent of the
value of all the warrants outstanding it
sounded like they were 66 percent
actually i believe the press release
makes exactly that point but
let's keep in mind that
when that press release was issued the
immediate response was that chase
said we'll go to a public auction
goldman
11 days later said we'll sell
at the panel's recommended price and
treasury said we will release more
information
about our sales process if the
consequence of this
report is to encourage those
sorts of responses then i'm i'm very
happy about that report you're back
thank you and uh chair will next
recognize congresswoman jackie spear
please
thank you mr chairman i want to thank
each of you as
being true public servants and
incredible guardians
of the american taxpayers
having said that i find this discussion
very interesting because on the one hand
some of my colleagues
often call upon us to think about small
businesses and lending to small
businesses and the fact that we haven't
had enough lending to small businesses
and yet we can't seem to get access to
information from the banks as to whether
or not they are lending to small
businesses and wouldn't we want to know
that
and isn't that what our job is really
all about now
i think we've got to be very practical
here this is an arms length transaction
that goes on between these financial
institutions
and the u.s government and these
warrants have value
now i think timing has everything to do
with our success at maximizing the
amount of money we get back for the
taxpayers
and it's very clear to me that there are
some of these
arrangements that aren't going to be
profitable aig comes to mind as
as one in particular so it's important
to us
i think to maximize profits
to compensate for the ones that are
clearly going to be underwater forever
and
i'm hoping that as you continue to
evaluate
if you believe that we should be holding
these assets
these warrants that we should hold those
it's an arm's length transaction if the
banks are coming to us now saying we we
want you
to exercise uh the the option on the
warrant or to redeem the warrant
they're saying that because they know
that they're on the road to recovery and
it's only going to increase in value
so it behooves us to be smart investors
right now and i would like your opinions
on whether or not there is something to
be gained
by holding on to them just because they
say they want them redeemed doesn't mean
we have to act
and redeem them our first and only goal
should be maximizing the profits for the
taxpayers
your comments congresswoman
i think you've put your finger right on
the ultimate policy question here
if that is the only goal and that is
what what treasury should be doing then
treasury should act like any other
investor and you are exactly right they
should take these to market when it's
appropriate to take them to market when
they make the
judgment that they would be better off
to hold than they should hold
there are those who believe there are
alternative considerations there are
those who are deeply concerned about the
notion that the federal government holds
warrants
we we ultimately believe that is a
policy choice there's a
there's a difference of opinion on which
is the right way to go with these
warrants
and my my strong view on this is that we
laid this out in our report
and ultimately congress should advise
treasury about
what it thinks is the right way to go
here i think we do this through this
this hearing process we want to say that
if what they're trying to do is maximize
value
we can point out ways that we think that
is best accomplished
if they have other considerations then
let me be blunt then they should
articulate what those alternative
considerations are and evaluate how much
money is left on the table in order to
accommodate them
thank you thank you mr profsky
i could not agree with professor warren
moore i think that's that's precisely
right i think that the report brought
transparency to the issue a decision
needs to be made and and
and i think the the really strong point
that the professor wire makes that i
can't agree with
more is that he need to be upfront in
articulating what the policy decision is
be up front with the american taxpayer
that we think there's good reasons to
liquidate these warrants now because for
whatever the reasons are for for the
benefits of the banks
let the financial institutions off the
hook whatever whatever the justification
is
but be upfront and honest about what's
happening so i agree with professor
warren on this
mr mccool again i would agree as well i
mean it's
it is there there are uh trade-offs here
and i think that
as long as you're transparent about the
trade-offs and uh and
everybody who should be involved in
thinking about those tradeoffs
is in the decision-making process then i
think that's the way it should work
all right uh mr chairman i would just
like to point out that there you know
there are people
who want to see the tarp fail they want
to be able to say
i told you so so there are people i
believe that are going to make us
try and take action that are not
necessarily in the best interests
of the public because they want to be
able to say at the end of
um the the process that we should never
have done in the first place
so i i hope that we keep our eye on on
what's
most important here and that is the
american taxpayer i yield back
i thank the gentlelady for her questions
and the witnesses for their responses
now i
next recognize the distinguished ranking
member of the full committee
mr backus thank you
i think i think the theme here could be
that oversight
worked i mean it worked very well
and i think that's always true of of
accountability or transparency it
it normally has a very positive approach
and i think that one of the
confirmations we got today i think that
the panel can be proud of is
is the goldman the price
it was exactly you know as you say it
was actually
20 million more than than you said and
so that maybe can pay for the panel
you know so this is a panel that
actually is going to end up making the
taxpayer some money and i you know often
the consumer the taxpayer is not at the
table
you know and i think they they were
through this panel
it's interesting the history is that
that this was originally a three-page
bill without any accountability
that i think the congress can take a bow
because we put that in there we put that
accountability in there
which was the board i think it worked
very well
um let's see
yeah one thing that we always have to if
we could look in the future and see
where the markets and the economy are
going it'd be pretty easy to
make a call on whether we ought to hold
it although
i personally don't think that the u.s
ought to be sort of investing or
speculating in the market which to a
certain extent
you know if you can get a good fair
price you you take it
now you know if the market dropped 600
points tomorrow and
300 the next day i would say hold
on to them probably but i you know and
that is a policy decision that i think
the administration probably will have to
make
um and uh you know it'll be with
they'll be you know in 10 years we can
probably tell what we should have done
you know one thing that did strike me
and i heard
four or five months ago from a banker in
alabama that he went to a seminar in
georgia
and there was a bank there in georgia
wanting to buy any saying if you're for
sale we want to buy you
and they were going to do it with their
tarp money so you did have four percent
that made acquisitions
you know it'd be kind of interesting to
maybe go back and take a closer look at
that
and uh mrs wrovsky i think they're going
to probably tell you the truth because
you have a
right to prosecute them and you have
that reputation that you're
very good prosecutors i think that that
now you know there will be some i'm sure
in that number
that actually were you know the fdic or
other people said this is a failing bank
and they probably
some i wouldn't assume that that four
percent was a bad thing
in and of itself um
i think the treasury has to understand
what what we have to understand as a
member of congress and that's this is
the people's money
so there needs to be accountability this
wasn't
you know this isn't just a a private
business where you're wanting to know
about
some proprietary thing this was money
that was that was taxpayer money
so i think that sometimes i think you
can't justify
you know some sorts of getting
information but i think you can hear
i think you've done a great job let me
change gears and
miss professor warren
i wrote a letter to you on june 24th
i've looked at some of those questions
some of them you know i'm not sure
that they're a little harder to
interpret sometime maybe
in august if you could kind of respond
to some of those i'd appreciate
but i'm not even going to ask you about
them now but
uh the other thing i just thought i'd
show you except my apology that you
don't have a response
well now there's too much going on
you you know with us in session you know
you please accept my apology
we i actually don't even think they're
due all right because i i don't think uh
i don't think it's sufficient time for
you to
to have responded because the questions
are really you know
they're kind of they're going to take a
little time
so but i just wanted to try one thing i
wanted to show
you and kind of at some point you might
give me an answer
you know we're talking about one page
disclosures
and this is actually 15 pages on a card
agreement
now some of these aren't you know
they're they're just part of the page
but that's what
the law requires right now so you got
you get quite a job
because you're going to have to almost
say you know well we're not going to
require this anymore
or maybe some of this you're going to
decide to put in small print but it does
show you the challenges you face
if you get your agency through
so thank you thank you
thank you sir next the chair
recognizes i usually ask questions
that's a very
very rare for me not to do that but i
there were no questions because i
thought the questions were answered
thank you thank you chair next
recognizes uh
congressman kilroy for five minutes
thank you mr chairman i appreciate it
and thanks all of you for your work
on helping to look out for the taxpayers
issue
and to make sure that the values of
transparency and accountability
are the values that we don't forget
as we
move further away from the initial
infusions of the tarp money
and each one of you have in your
testimony emphasize the importance of
transparency and
i would certainly agree with you i
certainly think sunshine
is a great great thing to have in the
public sector
but i also think that
in in this instance that transparency
can assist the taxpayers in getting
maximum value
maximum return on the investment that
they made
and i think the congressional oversight
panel report backs that up
it says treasury would be more likely to
maximize taxpayer returns
if it sold the warrants through auctions
the reason is straightforward
an auction would cause the warrants to
be allocated to the buyers willing to
pay the highest price
and competitive pressures in the bidding
process may push
bids up you agree with that that
statement
professor i do congresswoman
well i i certainly do as well
and i think that the the market and
public auctions are
certainly a a very valid way for
setting a price we've heard today a lot
of talk about
goldman and the
value that was received through the
negotiation process
with goldman but
not to be too pessimistic or too cynical
there are reports today that the initial
offer
from goldman was made several weeks ago
and the initial offer was 650 million
dollars
and that was followed up by a counter
offer
by treasury of some 900 million dollars
and then followed up sometime after that
by the release of
goldman's statements indicating how much
money
they had made certainly in part because
of the infusion of money
the taxpayers gave them
and as goldman stock prices go up
would you agree that the value of those
warrants that the taxpayers were holding
would also be going up yes
so then it's certainly maybe not
surprising that goldman increased its
offer
to the taxpayers and offered to pay 1.1
billion dollars for the warrants
you agree with that yes but would you
also agree
that perhaps if we allowed it to go to
market
that others who might see the same
reports about goldman's
recent earnings might think that holding
goldman's
warrants which could be used by them to
purchase stock
over a pretty lengthy period of time
might be to them worth more
than 1.1 billion dollars and they might
make a higher offer than that at public
auction
that is certainly possible congresswoman
so
you know would you agree that uh the
market has
a great deal of experience in this issue
of setting prices
and that treasury has also experienced
in terms of conducting public auction
yes congresswoman and and again going
back to all three of you in your
statements with respect to
maximizing value for the taxpayer and
being transparent and
would you agree that a public auction
would be an excellent way to combine
and achieve those two
those two goals maximizing profits and
being transparent
yes congresswoman anybody in the panel
have a different view
disagree i think in particular it
addresses a lot of the transparency
concerns and a lot of the
allegations that may be made when there
is when it is a closed door process
and that the the goal of restoring
public confidence in
in the markets and having public
confidence
in our government officials is important
and worthwhile goal as well i would
think
yes thank you i yield back
thank the gentlelady uh the chair now
recognizes mr mchenry congressman
henry for five minutes thank you mr
chairman uh thank you all for testifying
and
sorry for the length of the day it's
long for all of us
obviously mr barofsky i heard from you
yesterday in front of the oversight and
government reform committee which i'm a
member of
uh ms warren um in terms of
your panel the congressional oversight
panel uh what's your budget
uh we uh i can tell you how much we've
spent
but we actually is there a budget
allocation no we don't have a budget
allocation
how much have you spent we spent 2.7
billion a million
sorry you can tell the world i've been
dealing in
uh 2.7 million where did that money come
from is it out of tarp or is it out of
treasury it it it comes from
from the senate and from the house it
comes from you okay
how is that allocated i i'm i'm
i'm sorry basically you just spend
whatever you
want and send the bill to congress i
mean
that's what how is that allocated well
we we go through the process for example
of hiring
and getting your approval how many
people can you hire are you authorized
to hire
we we can hire as many as we need okay
that's enough
i i think it just shows that we don't
have a there isn't a clear budget mr
mccool is that
is that a fair assessment there's not
been a a
an appropriations for this committee
i don't really really know this is quite
a challenge
uh mr brofsky uh congressman i we we've
got the tarp to look after uh we haven't
looked into the funding for the
congressional oversight okay
our funding i certainly could speak on
if you'd like oh
absolutely inspector general's office is
is an appropriation yes
uh miss mccool uh in terms of your panel
meetings
uh uh sorry i'm sorry miss warren
i just i'm sorry i thought you said miss
mccool so i lost who you were talking to
i'm sorry late in the day
i don't have much time so uh
miss warren yes all right
is it true you have regular panel
meetings yes we do
okay are those publicly disclosed the
fact that we have the meetings yes
congressman no actually the panel
meetings
we have we have business working
meetings
that are not public meetings so you have
the panel of
how many members we have well we had a
five-member panel since senator
sununu has resigned we now have a
four-member panel okay
i presume it will be when you meet in
session
uh for the purposes of transacting
business is that uh
open to the public we have working
meetings that are not open to the public
okay
do you have a transcript or minutes of
that meeting uh
i don't have a transcript or minutes it
has it has a transcript
it is recorded by the senate uh
recording office
but no congressman i have not seen a
transcript okay
um is a transcript available of your
meetings
publicly not for members of congress is
that
available for your meetings it's not
available publicly no congressman
i'm not i'm a member of congress oh i'm
sorry
am i able to get a copy of the
transcript of your
meetings i believe our transcripts are
held in our office
and if you wanted to send something
would that be available read them
i believe you would be able to read them
okay if you wish to do that
so you'll make that available for
members if you if you wish to come to
our offices
okay why are the transcripts not
available to the public
there these are working meetings of
the panel and we discuss a great deal of
confidential
information and so they
were never public from the beginning we
do hold i should remind you congressman
we do hold
public hearings is this an executive
session
which you have this is what's
interesting to me you're an oversight
panel
yes yet you don't disclose your meetings
and and
what happens and what transpires in
these meetings and the decisions you
make the votes you take are there votes
taken at these meetings
there are sometimes so we don't even
know what the votes are
much less uh you know how this report
was
get created with this panel so there is
no disclosure from the oversight command
do you think that's perplexing or
strange
well we we have working meetings
where we discuss confidential
information we issue a public report
every 30 days
yeah and the report on that vote is made
public
every 30 days and each of the members is
entitled as part of that
process to add additional views if they
wish to do so
i think it's quite perplexing that that
oversight panel wouldn't disclose their
meetings
even you can redact confidential
information that's certainly in your
capacity
which is done throughout government but
it seems like this is a
very removed from the public and in been
pretty
pretty non-transparent for a board that
is demanding transparency from tarp
funds and
and the treasury in general do you find
that problematic
well what i would find if she could
if she'd be able to finish i i would
find it quite problematic
if we discussed sensitive
information about tarp recipients
about the inquiries and the lines of
inquiry
that we were pursuing and that
were a matter of public speculation
as soon as we finished saying it
i i my sense is we need an
opportunity to work together and that's
what we try to do
but we issue public reports every 30
days and
hold public hearings at least once a
month
thank you for the questions mr uh
mchenry and next the chair will
recognize uh
mr christopher lee five minutes give me
a
minute
uh thank you mr chair mr broski i'd just
like to ask a question
question i'm going to yield some of my
time but um just to follow up with some
of the discussion we had on the first
panel with mr allison
um it's been mentioned that some
companies have been getting mixed
signals mixed
answers in terms of what's coming out of
treasury on requirements for paying back
the payments or purchasing the warrants
i guess what the regulations or
stipulations might be for that there's
some frustration the work that your
office has done or seen have you found
that the government or treasury has been
very clear in terms of what it's
actually demanded
for repayment of those funds or has it
been foggy just
curious what your perspective might be
on that with respect to the warrants i
our audit is pending and ongoing so i'm
i'm not really prepared at this time to
to give a a you know sort of a
conclusion that would come out of that
audit
so it's a little bit premature for me to
answer that question okay
and i also have heard from you know some
in the small business community about
the way the stimulus or the tarp funds
have been distributed or handled
you know the committee had a hearing
yesterday on the whole issue of too big
to fail
the full committee and one of the things
that we think we've
missed is sort of the whole too small to
save or the concept of with small
community banks or small business what
the impact has been on where the
majority of those funds have gone to the
larger institutions but
after about six months now we've seen
the administration has started now
finally to talk about actually
looking at the small business angle and
focusing more on that that direction
which i think is smart and prudent
uh and as you know i think at the first
time i go around earlier this year we
had an amendment but that was before
this committee that would have added
authorizing legislation
uh that would have required you to
report on small business activity as
well as a part of
you know special inspector general's
obligations
on the next report is that something you
think you could look at
including in your next report just kind
of including some measures on
small business participation in the tarp
or small financial institutions
i think it would be what we could do is
is with the information that we already
have
maybe perhaps from the survey and what
banks are doing with respect to small
ending what their what they're saying
we don't really have the resources or
mechanism
to do exactly what you're saying that
really falls on treasury i mean that is
that is a basic part of treasury's i
think obligations under
you know under this this the concept of
transparency they should be doing that
assessment and making that information
available
it really goes to the heart of our
transparency recommendation about use of
funds
how are how are the institutions using
the funds with respect to small
businesses
and reporting on in their transaction
reports how what their steps they are
taking for small businesses
i'll be happy to to to work with you and
your staff and have my staff talk to you
if we could think out some other ways
where we could contribute to that
transparency
you know we're always open to
suggestions and and we look forward to
following up with you on that well i
appreciate it i i do want to commend you
for your work and you've been very
helpful i know the members on this
committee and i just like to yield the
balance of my time mr chair if i could
to mr mchenry
thank you i thank my colleague from
minnesota for yielding uh miss warren
just to follow up on this again
uh the fact that there is an unknown
budget
that hasn't been allocated and to my
knowledge
uh from the legislative branch
appropriations there wasn't a line item
for that
and i would ask the gao and i'd ask sig
tarp if if y'all
could take a look at that and and
perhaps
answer how that actually works if the
chair doesn't know
um additionally well i know you don't
have purview
my apologies i'm actually prohibited by
statute from doing that so
good um well it's it's late in the day
so obviously we're i'm missing a few
things here but
mr warren you've testified before this
committee about the
consumer financial protection agency
that's last month right yes congressman
okay
and i also saw a youtube video and i
think a few thousand others
saw it as well uh and your advocacy for
uh cfpa right yes congress um
and now is that part of your official
role as
head of the congressional oversight
panel no it's part of my role as a
professor at harvard law school
okay so that's done through your
official resources at harvard
yes it is okay and through my personal
resources i should say i wrote a check
for it
okay well youtube is actually pretty
cheap so
thankfully no i mean i wrote a check for
the for the
the the out-of-pocket expenses to be
able to produce
uh uh the video oh okay you got a
producer that's good
um yeah i understand it's youtube i
understand um
but you know and i there's a lot of
conjecture that you'd be the head of the
cfpa if congress does pass that
but no official resources under the
congressional oversight panel has been
used or staff has been used
in your advocacy okay good to know thank
you and i yield back
thank you next the chair recognized mr
lee
for five minutes thank you
before i start i do want to thank
everybody for your all three of you for
the support and what you're trying to do
to protect
taxpayers in the oversight i'm it's very
commendable
and i'll start off with mr barofsky
we've had a chance to meet in the past
and again it's been very accessible and
i appreciate
what you've been doing again one thing
that does scare me however is the fact
that uh
over you're under your oversight at risk
i'd heard numbers anywhere between 2.3
to 2.8 trillion dollars
and that the total potential support
government-wide in response to the
crisis since 07 could reach
close to 24 trillion those numbers
fairly accurate
yes to explain the the 24 trillion
though is to put it in context but what
we did in our report is
in in section 3 we gave a summary of
about
50 different support programs outside of
the tarp and for each of those programs
we calculated
how much is currently outstanding what
the high water mark was since uh
since the inception and then all what
the maximum amount that the the
government has said it would commit to
each of those programs
so the amount outstanding is about 3
trillion the high water mark was about
4.7
uh and the 23.7 trillion dollars that
represents that if everything was maxed
out at once it's
it's not uh likely that that would that
would ever occur but
i just want to put that caveat on there
not likely but off
a scary number all uh together but it is
absolutely
an accurate number of what the
government is committed to do to support
the financial system
well in june the congressional budget
office scored the tarp at a loss at
taxpayers to roughly 160
billion we're writing off billions in
loans to gm
chrysler yet it's unclear to me what we
are
doing with the funds being repaid by the
tarp recipients
in letters to the secretary of the
treasury and the president
which to my knowledge have at this point
been gone unanswered
many of us on this panel led by my
colleague mr mccarthy out of california
have advocated for those repayments to
be used
specifically to reduce the national debt
yet others want to recycle these funds
and use them for other programs
some of which are brand new i'm curious
from your perspective do you believe
it's in the best interest of the
taxpayer to take tarp repayments
to pay down the debt i mean our
perspective is really a legal one and i
think
legally treasury's treatment of taking
um
any interest or dividends and or profits
and directing the reduction of the
national debt
that's very clearly what's compelled by
law under esa the principal repayments
the treasury does have its position and
we think that is consistent with the law
is they have the option to re-let that
money out up to a maximum of seven
hundred billion dollars as long as tarp
is in existence
as long as uh permits them to do so
which is right now through the end of
the year
we uh the part that i keep hearing from
people
taxpayers that take the money back and
then we throw it out there and
keep adding more risk and eventually the
the
the debt obligation that we have is it
is staggered i'm just curious miss
warren from your
your point you've also been an advocate
on behalf of consumers
i.e the taxpayers i'm curious whether
you think taxpayers better served by
paying down the debt
or spending tarp for other purposes well
i
i think congressman this is really the
policy choice
that congress should be making and the
legislation
is ambiguous on this point and treasury
has made
its position clear that
it's going to use the head room analogy
that uh mr allison talked about so if
congress wants something different
then congress is going to have to pass
legislation i think to change that
with that i'm going to yield back thank
you
miss bachmann you are up for questions
please
mr chairman thank you and i agree thank
you all for being here i agree it's
it's a long day but you've all been very
responsive and we appreciate
the great information that you've made
available to us
i was curious i was listening to the
previous line of questioning
on meetings and help me did i understand
correctly
and i guess this would be miss warren
you had mentioned if a member of
congress requested
a transcript of one of these meetings of
the panel we could get it was that
true or didn't maybe i didn't understand
you know congresswoman i
i was surprised by the question so let
me
let me articulate more clearly we don't
have official transcripts unlike your
circumstances
where there are published transcripts
members go back and they correct the
language we identify who spoke and who
did not speak
we have no verified transcripts we have
no official transcripts
we have typing that comes back
from someone who listened to our tapes
who is not part of our panel
not part of this process and no one has
verified
the accuracy of any part of it so then
the meetings that you have that are not
the field hearings where it's
the four i guess it's four members now
was five members
when the five members meet or when the
four members meet
are those meetings recorded we have
working meetings that have been recorded
so those meetings are recorded so are
they transcribed or they're just in
recorded form
they're they're in recorded form and as
i understand
there is a transcription service so we
can get those transcribed
well it's possible for us to to have the
transcription of those meetings
i i actually i i have not considered
this question because no one had
asked and i am a little hesitant to
commit
my co-panelists to
um a process when these are unverified
transcripts that is
something contributed to someone who is
not their co
well and that i've never been verified i
think that's something that i would want
to know
as a member of congress if if the panel
is meeting
as a panel whether it's the five or the
four and if the meetings
are recorded it seems to me that they
could be
transcribed and i don't know what the
verification process is
the reason why i'm asking is because i
had learned yesterday
that two requests were made to access
those transcriptions and that those
requests
were not honored and i i
have no reason to doubt the calls for
transparency and that
the treasury department wants to be
transparent i have no reason to doubt
that at all
but it seems to me that that's in
conflict if on one hand the treasury
department is saying they want to be
transparent
on the other hand why can't we as
members of congress
at least receive transcribed copies or
even if we members of congress can't
receive the copies
couldn't the members of the panel that
sit on the panel
receive the copies of the transcribe of
the recorded
meetings congresswoman you may be aware
this is a matter of some discussion
within the panel
and the panelists themselves have
different views on this
and those views are currently under
discussion we have been trying to work
out
something that is congenial to all of
the panelists but i have to emphasize
these are working meetings where we
discuss
lines of inquiry that we are taking oh i
understand that and i understand
congressman mchenry said that it's
possible to redact material
one thing i had wondered i guess this is
a little off point but does the
congressional oversight panel have a
phone number
i i believe we do um you do okay
very good and can we get it i
certainly okay so then we would be able
to call and make that request
for the transcript for for the recording
or the transcriptions
as potentially as i said to congressman
mchenry
i believe it would be the case and i
really must add the qualification i am
as i said before
i am not the entire panel i have
so no decision has been made no decision
has been made about the transparency of
those hearings
we know that they aren't put up on the
public for record but
no decision has been made it just seems
to me odd that
we that if the commitment is
transparency that we wouldn't be able to
actually receive
those hearings because votes are made in
those meetings as i've said
congresswoman these are working meetings
i think perhaps the
correct analogy would be what's the
difference between working meetings and
like
and any other meeting what would be in
their public meetings where we do not
discuss
matters that would that should not be in
the public domain
but aren't these public meetings no they
are not they're meeting they're they're
meetings of the committee
they're formal meetings of the committee
members so these are
right working meetings no i don't know
what formal means these are
the meetings of the committee where the
panelists general women's time has
expired
and i will advise the witness the
members that if they have additional
questions or other questions would like
to pursue this you certainly have a
right to submit that in writing
mr chairman without objection the
hearing record will be remain open for
30 days for all members to submit
written questions and have their
responses and the questions put in the
record
sharon if i'm if i may just i
wanted to clarify what the witness said
in answer to my question versus
congresswoman bachmann and and i want to
make sure that's
i have the correct understanding if so
we've got another meeting scheduled for
this room at 5 30 so i'm going to deny
the gentleman's request and i'll ask you
well parliamentary inquiry
you have a right to submit written
questions and they'll be answered within
30 days
parliamentary inquiry yes sir is there a
what point will a transcript of this
meeting be available
i don't know that we have a transcript
of this meeting there
yeah there'll be one i don't know how we
if it generally deals with me
certainly we've got a pretty hard
working staff here seriously we've had a
lot of hearings
um but i would say this rather than wait
for a whole transcript
if there's a particular piece that the
gentleman is concerned about
we could have the uh stenographers
prepare that piece for him
thank you a whole transcript may may
take a while um
but a particular piece we could break it
out so
if you would designate to the staff what
you want to look at so you could
formulate your question based on that
you get it tomorrow okay thank you mr
chairman thank you mr chairman and again
i just want to thank all of the
witnesses for the testimony this
afternoon i think this gives us a better
understanding of how the tarp process
works we need to continue to keep
pressing for taxpayer protections
throughout tarp and i look forward to
working with republicans and democrats
these issues should not be partisan at
all we're all in this together
as well as the treasury department tarp
oversight organizations to finish this
and i thank again the witnesses
this hearing is concluded
you